now what you need to understand is that
it starts with us men
[Music]
there is a huge attack on the normal
healthy family structure parents spoke
out at a school board meeting hearing
about per child's class being showed a
movie with a gay character in it they
want to make men more feminine and they
want to make women more masculine it's a
view that celebrates destructive and
toxic behavior and hurts so many your
perceptions of the truth doesn't change
the truth itself they have identified 31
gender identities think how crazy this
world will become
they want you to be confused about what
it means to be a good man
you know a lot of people are falling for
this
[Applause]
hey guys
my blood is boiling
but before I just say another word watch
this so target has hired Eric a
self-proclaimed claimed gay trans man to
design some of its clothing for pride
month he's designed a Satan respects
pronouns t-shirt gay as hell stickers
and stained glass windows with the words
trans bodies are holy if you're at
Target because I heard that their new
Pride collection was out so let's take a
look this is a special swimsuit it is
invented for
tucking live laugh lesbian this right
here these are baby clothes they say
that grooming isn't happening then why
are there Pride baby onesies it's going
to uh a pride parade you get a little
pride skirt for your kid super queer
it's like a it's like a superpower
they're going after their cake
month posted on Twitter everyone in the
school Community should feel valued for
who they are and free to be their
authentic self our message to the
lgbtqia plus students teachers and staff
as we begin pride month is the education
department has got your back we begin
with the violent protests outside a
school board meeting in Glendale
California
[Applause]
they need to stop asking little children
what they sexually identify as
children are not sexual beings nor
should they be the sexualization of
children is pedophilia I'm completely
to decide about sexual things they don't
even know what's going on teaching a
six-year-old about sexuality I mean this
should be common sense but if you feel
similar to those parents and you want to
say in your child's education you might
get put on a hate group list we begin
with Ford so Ford has decided for pride
month they're going to release a rainbow
Ford F-150
when I think about queer I kind of think
that it's Unique in our own special way
Disney has decided they have to have
pride collections at Disneyland and that
you can't be called princesses or
princes at Disneyland anymore because
obviously the magic of childhood has to
be removed you never know when a boy is
a girl and a girl is a boy so Adidas
yep that is a lot of chest hair for um a
man dressed as a woman in a women's
bathing suit
foreign
let us pray Our Father sorry not anymore
our non-gendered parent Who Art in
Heaven that sound right to you in a
break with centuries of tradition the
Church of England's debating was to stop
referring to God as a he by introducing
gender-neutral pronouns in prayers yeah
recently in Florida a parent spoke out
at a school board meeting hearing about
her child's class being shown a movie
with a gay character in it and the
teacher of that class responded to those
complaints look at this
allowing movies such as this assist
teachers in opening a door for
conversations that have no place in our
classrooms these conversations these
doors that she's talking about that's
telling you I'm stripping her rights as
a parent those rights are gone when your
child's in the public school system
those rights are gone when you put your
kids in the public I'm sorry what
okay on to North Face North Face is all
about tough outdoor wear right you're
gonna go climb a mountain wearing North
Face or alternatively you're going to be
a dude who dresses up in ladies clothing
in galavants through the forest while
holding a TV Bud Light has taken it
directly on the chin ever since they
decided that they were going to make it
Dylan Mulvaney the face of their brand
it was April 1st I remember seeing this
online I thought this has to be April
fools I mean it has to be April fools
I'm going to show you a lot more Clips
in this video that will shock you to
your core
to show that these people are changing
the world as we know it okay this is the
child section this is literally the kids
section I'm next to a literal
what says whatever the hell that means
we have glad you came out and I'm so
happy that you're queer
in the kids section are you kidding me
so I found an extra small swimsuit in
the child section it says light binding
effect on it
and then the bottoms in the kids section
keep in mind
say
tuck friendly Construction
they're giving it to your kids if that
doesn't give you a reason to boycott
Target I don't know what does but
they're just getting out of hand they're
targeting children whether you like it
or not and it's time that people
actually do something about it why are
so many companies going woke there had
to be some reason and after some digging
I found it the CEI corporate equality
index aka the woke credit score it's a
made-up score based on how much a
company is pushing woke issues and who
made up and gives a score an
organization called the HRC a massive
political lobbying group apparently HRC
sends representatives to corporations
every year telling them the kind of
stuff they have to make visible at the
company give them a list of Demands and
if they don't follow through there's a
threat that they won't keep their CEI
credit score and why do companies even
care about this made-up woke credit
rating if they get a bad score then the
woke investor funds start putting
pressure on the boards woke activists
are mobilized out in the streets
advertising campaigns are shut down
anyone that continues to do business
with them will also be penalized this is
fascism don't play their game don't get
their investment and who is funding the
HRC surprise surprise it's George
soros's open Society Foundation now this
HRC has introduced this arbitrary credit
rating to everything States
municipalities and even schools imagine
that there are people who are deciding
what credit score an individual school
can get they threaten them by having
these big funds withhold investments
into them
these evil you know
I actually almost don't know where to
begin this video because these evil
people given over to their crazy debased
minds want to force their beliefs onto
you and your children
manipulating and controlling your lives
there's a quote that says controllers
abusers and manipulative people don't
question themselves they don't ask
themselves if the problem is them they
always say the problem is someone else
now what you need to understand is that
it starts with Usman
let me explain there is a huge attack on
the normal healthy family structure a
good man a good woman and good children
with good morals and values a healthy
family structure they want to break this
healthy family structure down because if
you have broken families you have broken
societies and it all mostly starts by
attacking the man they want you to be
confused about what it means to be a
good man with good values and good
morals
to be confused about what your roles and
your responsibilities are as a man like
being a good husband a good father a
good son a good brother and the list
goes on
there is an attack on what it means to
be a man on masculinity I'm going to
cover a few things here but first check
out this video
day 66 being a girl and today I'm in
nature
trees I love them
water lakes I love them
heels they're my hiking heels I love
them
Bridges love them
coconut water love it not mad just love
it
that is not what women are like
I think
it's very disrespectful against women
because women are a lot more than that
excuse me ma'am no porn at the bar oh
it's okay I'm transgender oh I I had no
idea do whatever you want all the time
this is what's happening these people
are victimizing themselves
so that people can just
let go and let these people do whatever
they want that is their agenda they're
not victims they are actually treated
like royalty in today's world
do you agree with I mean obviously you
do there there is a
massive shortage of even knowing what a
man is supposed to be in today's world
now there's no question I mean I
actually wrote the book everybody knows
that manhood's in crisis in our
generation
like all of us ideas of masculinity are
evolving
today you may get a deserved side eye if
you say things that used to be
commonplace like real men don't cry or
boys will be boys waves of feminist
critique and the metoo movement have
called out behavior that used to enjoy
impunity and now faces greater demands
for accountability today the view that
you're only a real man of your dominant
or aggressive is thankfully on the
defensive and thank you for that it's a
view that celebrates destructive and
toxic behavior and hurts so many and not
just women the phrase toxic masculinity
might once have been reserved for the
fringes of the national conversation but
increasingly in schools and workplaces
and on media Outlets like this one it is
a conversation we are having together
they've tried it and you came to
prominence in part over your opposition
to this law that we just talked about in
Canada proposing the use of preferred
pronouns for transgender people
mandating them yeah right so you should
do it no but you had to do it right you
had to do it by law but just for clarity
do you think a trans woman is a real
woman
I don't really like the way those
questions are formulated you know I
don't know what that means what do you
mean a real woman well I'm asking you in
your mind you know it depends what you
think a real woman is but do you think a
trans woman is a woman
no
why not
because I think that women are capable
generally speaking of having babies and
they have female genitalia and they have
an XX chromosome and and I think the
biological markers are relevant it
doesn't necessarily mean that I don't
think that people should be treated with
respect and dignity if they happen not
to fit easily into a gender category
that's a different issue you see they
are compelling speech now they've never
done this before if you look in history
they're taking away your freedom you can
even be fined now for not addressing
someone with the right pronouns
as I suggested earlier in New York City
they have identified 31 gender
identities and apparently the law down
there suggests that if businesses don't
accommodate an individual's chosen
gender identity there is the risk of a
six-figure fine under the rule the rules
rather of the city's Commissioner of
Human Rights we have in the province of
Ontario our own Ontario Human Rights
Commission you know a lot of people are
falling for this
because they make it an emotional issue
where it's actually not they want to put
new laws in place you need to be careful
and look out for this because they want
to put these laws in place and they want
to mask it with a big show of compassion
now before I continue let me just make
this clear I do agree that toxic
masculinity is wrong I hope you have the
correct understanding of what toxic
masculinity is I believe it is wrong
when men want to dominate others through
Force beating other men or women to a
pulp or beating their own children to a
pulp and some of these men feeling that
they should never talk about their
emotions or even cry
but we are not women either
we need to live a balanced healthy life
as men for ourselves for our family and
for those around us because you see if
we're responsible responsible
masculinity
overcomes toxic masculinity so there is
a balance
there is an extreme of toxic masculinity
that's dangerous then there's the Other
Extreme of being
well not having a balanced life being
too feminine and too emotional all the
time being controlled by our emotions
then we are no different than animals
we're just controlled slaves to our
emotions think how crazy this world will
become if men live this way no we need
to have self-control self-discipline
because only animals give in to their
emotions all the time and do whatever
they want all the time
I masculinity as your new big issue well
I think what the left is doing is
attacking America they're saying that
America's systemically oppressive and
men are systemically responsible if you
look closely at what is happening around
the world you will see that he is right
now if you look carefully you'll notice
that political and media leaders on the
left are slowly chipping away at this
idea of masculinity in other words what
it means to be a man
don't believe me well check out this
discussion of School shooters on MSNBC
it has been told to man up
what does that mean no clue so no
emotion yeah yeah what's the hardest
part about growing up for boys
hiding the pain yeah not being able to
express yourself
again there is a balance the one
extremist is you're just giving to your
emotions you're a slave to your feelings
and you just cry and complain about
everything you don't have a backbone to
stand up for what is right
and instead of just doing what needs to
be done to get things done instead you
just sit back and complain about
everything playing the victim the other
one is
that you are toxic you want to do things
with violence all the time you beat
women you beat children you beat other
men and you never talk about your
emotions not one of those two
is real masculinity check it out
talk about this like when I hear these
attacks on on masculinity I I hear the
left equating masculine what it means to
be masculine with abusive or criminality
that specific MSNBC segment was talking
about is the fact that rigid gender
roles specifically in boys are tied to
higher rates of suicide substance abuse
uh violence so it's basically saying
that these gender roles are creating an
environment in which men feel that they
men and boys feel that they can't
express themselves
what but Julie how is that
connected gender I mean we've had gender
roles for I don't know Millennia so so
we're like well gender roles are causing
boys to commit suicide well maybe
there's a lot of societal factors
involved in drug abuse in promiscuity
and you know shaming in uh substance
abuse of other types addictions yeah
there are many other factors that we can
include here but these people their
agenda they just want to focus on gender
roles all the time everywhere you look
there is a backlash against masculinity
and they now view normal masculinity as
toxic the normal identity of a man
should now be viewed as toxic Jordan
Peterson also talks about it listen to
this
I believe that there's a danger in our
society at the moment of making the
assumption that our culture for example
is a tyrannical patriarchy which it is
in some small part and that any active
engagement on the part of young men in
particular is indistinguishable from an
unacceptable power and dominant Strife
which I don't believe but surely all of
that is if we had an incorrect if much
of the power and authority over a very
long historical period is laying with
men isn't it only inevitable that some
men will get a little hacked off when
women are given a a star but something
approaching equality well that could be
inevitable but that doesn't make it
right and it's certainly not something
that I support
so you think men's resentment is more
important than women's effort to attain
equality not in favor of resentment at
all I think that if you resentful
something's something's definitely wrong
either you need to grow the hell up and
and and take stock of your life or you
have some things to say to people that
you haven't been saying you say science
undoubtedly shows us that men and women
have different traits and there's a lot
of signs to to back you up on that but
you say that because of that men are
hardwired to achieve success and to be
successful in a way that women are not
no not at all I've never said anything
like that I've said that there are
biological differences between men and
women that Express themselves in
temperament and and an occupational
choice and that any attempt to enforce
equality of outcome is unwarranted and
ill-advised as a consequence I fully
agree with him here because equality of
outcome is a terrible idea it will never
stop it will never be fair
so we should focus a lot more on
equality when it comes to opportunity
give everyone the same opportunity right
and then you can choose what you want to
do you will always see if you let people
alone certain men would want to do
certain jobs more than other jobs and
women would do certain jobs more than
other jobs and that's okay let people
just do what they want to do for example
more men might be interested to play
rugby or choose engineering as a career
path and more women might choose to be
health workers and that is okay look my
view is this if there's 90 women in a
certain career and we all had the same
opportunity men and women and that's the
outcome 90 women they love to do this
then that's fine if they're great at it
great
all men will be happy with it if it's
the other way around it's the same thing
if everybody had the same opportunity
and the outcome is that 70 80 percent
are men then so what for both sides
leave men and women alone let them do
what they want to do we should stop
forcing people to do stuff that they
don't want to do
men and women are different men have
similarities and women have similarities
and then there are also differences
within each sex group because not all
men or all women are the same now I'm
talking to those of you who want to
force these things on us stop comparing
us to women forcing us to be more like
women and stop forcing women to be more
like us because that's what you're also
doing these days
no we should focus on our uniqueness and
differences and then use that to help
one another
it's as easy as that now check this out
I think it's a self-perpetuating problem
meaning that there are crappy men in the
world right but men are crappy because
we've created a system where manhood has
become obsolete you keep increasingly
telling men more and more they can't
matter when I say who are they being
told that by you know they're like I
said there's there's more Sinister
implications here of why we're making
manhood obsolete when we're saying
masculinity is wrong this is wrong this
is backwards you don't need a man uh you
can you can just have a baby without a
man you're starting to see that sort of
programming happening with young women
it's like why is society communicating
to men to be more feminine yeah at the
same time that you're telling women to
be more masculine right that's like just
take a step back and think you don't
have to like Candace Owens to take a
step back and go that is kind of weird
right it is a bit weird that you're
telling men oh all displays of
masculinity are wrong and you need to be
more feminine and and telling men they
can bend gender and do all these things
while at the same time you're saying to
a woman you need to man up you need to
provide you need to do this you can do
that that tells you that there's
something satanic going on right Dr
Kumar can biological man become pregnant
and give birth
um so men can have pregnancies
especially trans men so can biological
men become pregnant and give birth so
are you saying that a biological female
who identifies as a man and therefore
becomes pregnant is quote a man is that
what you're saying these questions about
who can become pregnant are really
missing the point I'm here to talk no no
no no no no no this is me asking a
question and you answering I'm asking
the question sir not you right and I'm
answering the question somebody with a
uterus may have a capability of becoming
pregnant whether they're a woman or a
man that doesn't mean okay we're done
not every person this isn't complicated
let me tell you if a person has this
medicine and is born as a is born female
they are a woman are now trying to tell
us that transgender people are not real
and um I would say that their claim uh
is probably just as legitimate as all
their others which is to say not very
much at all no it's a fact that males
cannot give birth to babies
and no people are not saying that these
people who identify as
fairies or unicorns or Wolves or other
kind of sexes do not exist
we're saying that their claims
is not truthful you can't say that
suddenly believing a lie makes it true
makes it reality
Let's test that you can say your truth
is that whales have legs and walking
land
but they don't do they you can say
elephants are pink but that doesn't
change the reality does it
if you're obese you can say that you're
super skinny or you can say that your
skin in you're obese but that doesn't
change the reality does it
if you're 60 years old and you say
you're 20 years old it doesn't make you
younger does it crazy beliefs doesn't
suddenly just change the natural laws of
the universe
your perceptions of the truth doesn't
change the truth itself reality truth it
doesn't change
cannot change so stop forcing your
beliefs onto other people forcing them
to believe your perceptions of reality
you can tell them what you believe it is
your right you can tell them but it is
their right to say all right
um
I'm not going to believe you other
people can say all right I'm going to
believe you but you can't force them if
you're a man and you tell me that you're
a unicorn
and you tell me that I have to believe
that I'm not going to believe that
because I see a man pretending to be a
unicorn and that is the truth that I
will speak
watch this on Friday we've talked about
Harry Styles's Vogue cover he's the
first guy to Grace the cover solo so
Harry gets playful with clothing inside
the pages including this gown he says
that clothes are meant to have meant to
have fun with and experience with and
once you remove the male female barriers
to clothes it opens up more Arenas to
play
they want to make men more feminine and
they want to make women more masculine
Vogue basically said that this is
groundbreaking it was amazing
if you're a young man struggling with
your identity then please listen to me
today
if you were born a male biologically a
male
then you are not a female
even if you might be more sensitive or
certain things going on
you are still a male there are different
men out there we are not the same some
are more sensitive than others and
that's just the way it is the X and Y
chromosomes known as the six hormones
you get from your parents determine if
you're a male or female
and you parents please listen to me
today because most of the problems we
have today comes from parents
most of you just working all the time
and never spending time with your kids
expecting the government through the
education system to somehow educate your
kid to be a healthy man and then being
angry when it doesn't happen it's your
responsibility
never tell
your son that he is a daughter I mean
they're too young to understand these
things
especially if for example your son is
very young plays with Barbies it doesn't
mean that he's now a female
it might just be because he's bored and
he wants to play with toys
wait until he's older to understand
things and he can decide what he wants
to do with his own life
check this out so uh you guys were
talking about uh toxic masculinity
earlier and I just wanted to ask um
should we uh separate um maybe not that
masculinity is toxic right but instead
that uh it is some aspects that could
result in toxic Behavior right like
aggression is an example So my answer is
first off we didn't
actually I just talked about masculinity
and I said that I like masculinity and I
think it should be promoted the answer
to your question is just no I think it's
okay for boys to be boys and I think if
you're talking about
um young men I'm just thinking right now
the Gillette commercial wrestling and
now that's being called aggressive I
grew up with my brothers and my cousins
wrestling they would wrestle me when I
was a small girl that was an aggressive
behavior
um and I think that we need to stop
making men being men and stop using
these words like aggressive to to make
it seem like there's something wrong
with it I'm actually really opposed to
this made-up term toxic masculinity
toxic masculinity is a term that was
made up by toxic feminists
identity politics is making Society
unstable because it's breaking down
healthy family structures
did you know that most children find
their identity from their father
I learned this back when I studied
psychology to become healthy adults they
might not know who or what they are
either
you know when you have a father who
doesn't know who he is what a man really
is and then he goes on fathering boys to
become healthy adults they might grow up
not knowing who they are
and so they want to create their own
identities and school systems say yes
and they help them actually leaning
towards the opposite direction
check out this clip from the daily wire
what does it look like for for children
to be brainwashed well here it is it's a
bunch of children sitting around on a on
the carpet listening to a cross-dressing
man reading a book about transgenderism
this isn't really the most important
point the most important point is simply
that the school district and these two
men and everyone else involved are
guilty of abusing these children they
are all agents of ideology they are not
Educators they are not fit to educate
but
let's let's also examine what they told
these kids
I have a girl brain but a boy body this
is called transgender I Was Born This
Way
when I was very little and my mom would
say you're such a good boy I would say
no mama good girl
at first my family was confused they'd
always thought of me as a boy
as I got a little older I hardly ever
played with trucks or tools or
superheroes only princesses and mermaid
costumes my brothers told me this was
girl stuff I kept right on playing a
child at two two or three years old or
however old Jazz was
um
saying I'm a girl
well that means nothing at all because a
three-year-old child has no idea what a
girl is
yes I agree my brother's little boy says
he's a dinosaur but he just plays as a
dinosaur he knows he's not really a
dinosaur
oh you know these people who are this is
just pure evil they could have read this
book to your kids in school without you
knowing about it
let that sink in for a moment
they're telling these kids that they can
create their own identities even when
he's not true some parents even allow
their kids to have sex changes
at an age where they can't understand
these things
and then fast forward they reach an age
where they start to understand these
things and then
they regret it
but they can't do anything about it it's
too late they can't go back and change
it
check this out
I am Helena I'm 23 years old
when I was about 15 I started using
Tumblr I had an eating disorder since I
was pretty young there's a lot of
messages that said if you feel bad about
your body that means you're trans I was
just going through this period of like
I don't like how I'm treated as a CIS
person I don't want to be CIS because
CIS means you're uncool and you're
privileged and you're an oppressor and
you're bad and I don't want to be that
in that way I was really incentivized to
try to figure out a way
to make my voice heard
in these communities and obviously I
can't change my race I can't really
change my sexuality so the only thing
left was to start playing around with
the gender stuff
so I decided to call myself a demi girl
which is one of the 40 million genders
and that basically means that I'm mostly
a girl but I'm a little bit not a girl
which is just like what does that even
mean and then after that I went to Demi
boy and then after that I went to gender
gender fluid and after that I eventually
went to trans boy but all this took like
two or three years of just going through
this repetitive cycle of changing this
identity and changing it again and it
was just never enough
[Music]
there is a lot of hopelessness for a
long time a lot of regret
the feeling of regret was intense
Ruby began identifying as male at 13
years old now 21 she'd been planning to
have surgery to remove her breasts but
in May she made the decision to come off
testosterone and de-transition to
identify as female her sex at Birth
she doesn't want to be identified so
we've changed her name I figured it
would be better for me to try to deal
with my gender dysphoria in a different
way rather than
um permanently changing my body
and how much support did you feel was
out there for you when you came to this
conclusion I didn't feel like there was
any support out there other than like a
few friends online Ruby now feels her
eating disorder was more of a factor
than she first realized in her gender
dysphoria none of the therapists that I
spoke to
um brought that up they didn't think
that it was linked
do you I think so yes because it they're
both kind of based in how I feel about
my body so
I've seen similarities between the two
Charlie Evans is forming a charity to
support people in Ruby's position after
going public with her detransition story
she discovered an online community of 5
000 in a similar position 30 people
alone in her area of Newcastle I was
approached by a young woman
um
with a beard and she hugged me and and
said
I'm a de-transitioned woman as well I've
just stopped taking testosterone and
after that I felt like I had to do
something I'm hearing from hundreds of
people at this point in a transition
with all of the pressure and all the
things going on certainly this is the
key time in a transgender's life and
certainly is exciting but I worry about
the time when the lights go off and the
shows go off and all of a sudden
you know nobody's around you're there
with your private as we say you're there
with your private thought and I enjoyed
it what went wrong
well after about eight years and I
started studying psychology uh because I
wanted to become a counselor and help
people I started to realize that there's
a lot of other things that that hadn't
been talked about regarding transgenders
and I learned that many transgenders
suffer from what we call comorbid
disorders they're secondary uh disorders
that are not diagnosed prior to surgery
such as separation anxiety dissociative
disorders bipolar disorders
documented but it also has to be
informed and informed means you have to
understand what you're consenting to
you needed to be walked through in great
detail
all of the issues that were relevant to
you on the psychological and medical
front all the options that were
available to you and the pros and cons
of all those options I can't see in any
possible way that that could have been
done with any degree of thoroughness in
something under six months of weekly
therapy and I would say that's an
absolute minimum to walk anyone through
something as complicated as what you
laid out
the problem with me starting it so young
was not only that I couldn't consent I
couldn't really fathom
the full just the full picture of things
you know I'll never be able to
breastfeed I'll never have that
erogenous sensation in my chest back
I do I do hate to speak about it but
I'm experiencing
sexual dysfunction at the age of 18.
that's something that women usually go
through
when
when they're in their 40s to 50s
how is this supposed to know
do you see what is happening there are
thousands of these stories but the media
won't show it to you
because they have an agenda
now to those of you who are still
struggling with your identity I want to
talk directly to you I'm telling you
these things because I actually do care
about you because I love you and I want
you to know the truth I don't want you
to be deceived by some crazy person and
make the wrong choice
you've been created
for a reason you're not a just a mix of
chemicals and boom there you are with no
purpose no reason that you're here God
created you
and he loves you
he created you as a male or a female
he knows what your true purpose is who
you are you can only find your true
identity in God the Bible says in
Genesis 1 verse 27 so God created man in
his own image in the image of God he
created him male and female he created
them David a man close to God's heart
knew this truth
and he said this but I want you to put
yourself in his shoes and say it with
him
Psalm 139 verse 13. for you form my
inward parts
you knitted me together in my mother's
womb
I praise you
for I am fearfully and wonderfully made
wonderful are your works
my soul knows it very well
my frame was not hidden from you when I
was being made in secret
intricately woven in the depths of the
Earth
your eyes saw my unformed substance
in your book were written every one of
them
the days that were formed for me
when as yet there was none of them
you know God knew you thousands of years
ago yeah that's right even before you
existed he knew that you would live here
in this time in this moment
he's not controlled by time he created
time these evil people they create lies
to lure you away from God
from understanding who God is and who
you truly are to live in this made up
fantasy world that they create a world
that doesn't really exist at all
this lifestyle of identifying as
anything you want to even if that's a
fairy is psychologically very unhealthy
check this out and I want to hear what
you think in the comment section down
below
receiving Paradox the wolf I am your
Blue Fox host Pharaoh I'm your co-host
in training shroud the leopard I'm your
guest menok the raccoon on all levels
except physical I am a wolf
so Avery and I are both Birds I am a
cardinal and Avery is a blue jay
we like am air pronouns in particular
because they feel even further removed
from gender than they than theirs and
being Birds while we do have
um our own gender expression we don't
inherently have a gender at all I um
have a mommy and daddy adopted mummy and
daddy who are totally comfortable with
me being a little girl and their
children and their grandchildren are
totally supportive in fact her youngest
granddaughter when I was eight a year
ago I was eight and she was seven and
she said to me I want you to be the
little sister so I'll be nine I said
well I don't mind going to six so I've
been six ever since but we have a great
time and we color we do kids stuff it's
called play therapy no medication no
suicide thoughts and I just get to play
um
I don't even know what we just looked at
this is just
shocking
so this grown-up man
pretends to be a kid so he can get free
food probably right all the time he
doesn't have to work now right because
he's a kid so he doesn't contribute
anything to society as well and he's
just lazy
just see where the world is going to
Lords it's just
I have no words
so we're living in a world where the
crazies are allowed to make the new
rules of how Society should live not
only are they not happy enough just
about making their own decisions and
living as crazy people but they want to
force those beliefs onto US
forcing what you should believe that
means they're actually taking away your
freedom
and they want you to stay quiet and not
say anything against them because they
want you to be afraid because if you do
say anything you'll be a sexist racist
and the list just goes on they tell you
how you should live your life and they
can also actually harm you
psychologically and physically
you think I'm I'm not talking the truth
it's already happening watch this and I
work out regularly at the Santee YMCA
just two weeks ago after finishing my
shift at my job I went to the gym to
swim laps
as I was showering after my workout I
saw a naked male in the women's locker
room
I immediately went back into the shower
terrified and hid behind their flimsy
excuse for a curtain until he was gone
I ran into a bathroom stall to change as
quickly as I could organizing my
thoughts to share with the people at the
front desk
as I did so I could only think of my
five-year-old sister who I bring to this
gym during the summer
sorry to enjoy their water slides
this is the YMCA
where hundreds of children spend their
summer afternoons in child care camps
this is the YMCA where my little sister
took gymnastics lessons
the locker room was supposed to be her
safe haven to gossip with her friends
and shower and change
when I asked the OMC management what
their policy was regarding transgenders
they confirmed that the man that I saw
was indeed allowed to shower wherever he
pleased as long as you are not a red
flag on Megan's Law
the California sex offender registry a
grown male can shower alongside a
teenage girl at your YMCA location here
in Santee
in an effort by the city and the YMCA to
apply the neocultural gender rules at
Mountain View pool dressing shower room
facilities women and children are being
put at risk
my experience while showering after my
swim was hearing a man's voice in the
women's dressing area and seeing a man
in a women's swimsuit watching little
girls pull down their bathing suits in
order to use the toilets in the dressing
room
I reacted by telling him to leave and
the consequence is that I have been
banned from the pool
it's okay for
hey for little girls under age you're
Spa we Spa condone that is that what
you're saying
like I asked
it's so he can stay there
he could stay there
okay no I'm not one actually I'm a woman
who knows how to stand up and speak up
from my right as a woman I have a right
to feel comfortable without a man
exposing himself okay no you go
somewhere else okay so that's right no
he's not a transgender he has a penis
just like you do are you are you are you
are you do I understand
okay it's not okay it's not okay okay
that's traumatizing to see that I'm a
woman I think this is a place right here
I'm told only for women so how dare you
sit up here and tell me I don't have a
right as a woman
I'm telling you he has a penis a full in
testicle okay and I don't care what it's
called it's a man you got one you're a
man here are the facts surrounding Paul
Bixler he's a 72 year old biological man
for the most of his life he has been
married has two children he has lived
the life of a biological man he is
attracted to women he was married to a
woman
30 40 years he sits on the school board
of an elementary school in Buckeye
Arizona called Liberty Elementary this
man is claiming to be a woman it's a bad
picture hold on there we go this man
tells the little children at the school
that he is a woman he wears clothing he
wears lipstick and he uses the same
restroom the same restroom as your
little girls
he also uses the women's locker room at
esport of Fitness in Goodyear Arizona he
has been spotted yesterday in the
women's locker room in esport of Fitness
in Goodyear Arizona
he went on local television claiming
victimhood because people like myself
parents who have the right to speak up
against their elected officials are
harassing and bullying him
Paul Bixler cannot be voted off the
school board he must either willingly
step down or be recalled the recall is
being started I am at the gym in Arizona
who's undressing in the locker room top
off
and a pub mixler was in the women's
locker room and he looked at me and he
looked at my breasts and I have called
the police
so
I have told the police that I was in the
locker room a man was in there I was
getting undressed he looked at me he is
a man in the women's locker room
and the response is that this is a
touchy sensitive issue in society
there's the man going in the women's
soccer room
oh there's no one undressing in there
you know
I keep thinking you know what would the
people think who found America when they
look at American now what they fought
for
the blood that they lost
if they could imagine what we're going
through were they fighting for this were
they fighting for this
um
it's kind of crazy and totally
inconceivable
but it's actually happening
I mean these things are
in South Africa even now as well
people gave their lives for the freedom
that we have
and I want to tell you if you are a male
identifying as a woman and you go into
the bathroom where another man's wife is
undressing and maybe even his little
daughter a five-year-old
if you want to play by that game those
rules then he has the right to also
identify as something
like a boxer and knock you out
oh wait they got that covered as well
because you can't be a man and protect
your family anymore because now that is
masculinity
toxic masculinity isn't it so men cannot
protect their own families against other
men anymore
no we have to the Bible says in one
Corinthians 16 13 Be watchful
stand firm in the faith
act like men
be strong
let all that you do be done in love
it's time you open up your eyes
you need to see what's going on here a
lot of men who know that they are not
identifying as women can just say that
they are identifying as women and go
into bathrooms public toilets and rape
women molest women your kids are not
safe anymore the same can happen the
other way around women can go into men's
bathroom do stuff with little boys open
up your eyes you think it doesn't matter
who you vote for in elections look at
the laws these sick people put in place
don't look for all the politics and
what's going on in the news look at the
laws that they want to put in place and
then you will know who they really are
you vote for them
and then they're taking your freedom
away
they want to defend criminals
and you now as the victim
they look at and say that you're the
criminal you're the offender here in
South Africa according to the male and
guardian there are 115 rapes a day those
are only the numbers that's being
reported
I live here in South Africa and I know
what the community is thinking a lot of
people don't even go to the police
anymore
just the other day we had an incident
where someone was mugged and when they
got to the police station they wanted to
report the crime and they looked at the
person who did it the police officer
the police officers here are criminals
the number of kids being molested in
South Africa is a lot more than the rape
numbers
and I'm just warning a lot of you
countries out there
that your country is gonna become like
this if you don't do anything about it
and then there's Paul Val he's 40 from
Davenport
he's married
he works at Disney World at cosmic rays
restaurant in fact he just recently
moved to Polk County from Indiana and he
moved here specifically to work at
Disney World
well you know back in the day they
arrested Willie Sutton for Robin Banks
he was a notorious bank robber
and they asked Willie Sutton hey Willie
why do you rob banks and he said well
that's where the money is
well why do people like Paul Vell work
at Disney because that's where the
children are
and they want to be around children
he had 540 counts of child pornography
from newborns to eight years of age
he also had videos
and he's he was a savior masochist
there was photographs where they had
tied up babies in preparation for sexual
battery in South Africa we lived in
fenced up communities Barbed wires we
have to protect ourselves all the time
we have probably around 60 murders every
day now
we are only a tiny country of 59 million
compared to over 300 million in America
for example
the whole world is changing you need to
understand this and you need to fight
for truth
if you are a man
they're even taking away the rights of
women now because if you are a
biological male that says that you're a
female you can now compete in female
sports
meaning you can steal the trophy
I mean as a man
in women's sports that's just not fair
technological mail has just become the
first transgender person to win a world
title in cycling first transgender
weightlifter winning who made an
international event as a woman a
biological male winning a gold medal in
a women's event now seems a matter of
when not if look this is not funny this
is serious this is you know for all
those women who work so hard who train
so hard daily to make sport a career
this is a slap in their face
you know it is sad that a lot of people
these days are so selfish and they don't
really care about other people that's
why you have this saying where if you
don't see it it doesn't hurt that's why
I'm showing you these clips so that you
can see what is going on
check this out
oh we're gonna give you two pictures and
we're gonna ask you to identify which
one of these people is a biological man
do you think you can do that I hope so
man I think I'm gonna have to go with
this one that is correct that is a
biological man how did you guess
oh gee he's got a large
muscles a square jaw
you are correct that is mountie he is
from Australia uh he is a rugby player
and he is I believe almost six foot five
he is enormous right or left which one
is a man yeah that would be the right
and what makes you say that
there's no way totally different I mean
he's clearly a man with his body his
muscles still looks like a guy still
looks like a guy I'm noticing a pattern
here absolutely
absolutely was allowed at the Olympics
um the highest competition you can have
it's easy let women compete against
women and let men who claim to be women
compete against other men who claim to
be women
let's just stop the let's just stop the
games here you can clearly see when a
man is a man
competitive swimmers right and left
which one is a man like a guy I'm a
really tall girl and I'm still nowhere
close to that so I have personal
experience swimming against Thomas about
a foot and a half taller than me
um you would jump in the pool and it's
it's already you know like a body length
ahead and I definitely know that one is
the male as somebody who's here who
clearly was able to tell a biological
man from biological woman what is the
difference as a woman I think it's the
most anti-anti woman thing that could
even possibly just done to say that a
man is a woman they're clearly different
like we're trying to defy science and
that is a bit crazy it's common sense
it's not anything that's meant to be
extremely hurtful it's just you know
using our brains and making a decision
and that's exactly what's happening and
it's blatantly obvious people are
changing worldwide at an insane rate
crime is increasing every day and most
of it comes from evil people controlling
entertainment the media and big
corporations people with too much power
who say things like this it violated the
platform's Hacked materials policy in
reality the Twitter Executives were
hostile towards conservatives and biased
towards anyone who opposed their points
of view for example Mr Roth did you
write this tweet
I regret the language that I used in
some of my former tweets but yes I did
post that and I'll read the Tweet so
it's in the record yes that person in
the pink hat is clearly a bigger threat
to your brand of feminism than actual
Nazis in the White House Baker Miss
Gatti Mr Roth and miss navaroli you can
consider your speech canceled during my
time because you canceled mine
it's amazing to me Mr Roth as the head
and Trust
of safety at Twitter
your ability or should I say inability
to remove child
here's something that disgusts me about
you and your doctoral dissertation
entitled gay data you argued that minors
should have access to Grindr an adult
male gay hookup app miners really
you know Elon Musk took over Twitter and
he banned 44 000 accounts that were
promoting child
you permanently banned my Twitter
account but you allowed child child all
over Twitter
had become a platform you said
connecting queer young adults you also
wrote on Twitter in 2010 can high school
students ever meaningfully consent to
sex with their teachers
in 2021 while you were the director of
trust and safety on Twitter an underage
boy and his mother announced a lawsuit
against Twitter
because because Twitter was benefiting
from and refused to remove a lewd video
featuring this boy and another minor
that is repulsive
sick isn't it
you know that's just one example behind
all these crazy people there's a group
of people who want to create chaos and
destruction in the world so that they
can come up and say hey we're the
saviors we want to change everything
here's a new system we propose where you
will own absolutely nothing
but be happy
doesn't make sense does it it's like
saying hey we're gonna take all your
freedom away and you need to be happy
about it and pay us all your money all
your taxes and give us all control of
your life
doesn't even make sense
historical moments a Time
only to fight Surya virus but to shape
the system we have a unique but rapidly
shrinking window of opportunity to learn
lessons and reset ourselves on a more
sustainable path
it is an opportunity we have never had
before I may never have a game
so we must use all the levers we have at
our disposal knowing that each and every
one of us has a vital role to play the
great reset is a welcome recognition
that these human tragedy must be a
wake-up call it is imperative that we
reimagine rebuild redesign reinvigorate
and rebalance our worlds rebalancing
investment harnessing science and
technology and advancing the transition
to net zero emissions all elements of
the great reset are fundamental to
building the future we need
and that last one was the clown
guitarist who was at the climate
ambition Summit telling us the world is
going to cook by three and a half
degrees or something by the end of the
century yeah right this great reset is
as serious and as dangerous a threat to
our prosperity to your prosperity and
your freedom as we have faced in decades
with these powerful bodies including the
world economic Forum the United Nations
the international monetary fund and even
Prince Charles boasting yes boasting
that when a few within a few short years
yes their words you will own nothing and
you will be happy remember this is not
me saying this this is them they are
even running ads for the great reset
[Music]
thank you
handful of countries will dominate I
wonder which ones they might be the last
few years
it's been crazy if my great grandparents
would see what's going on today they
would not believe it and you know those
Generations who fought first world war
second
oh
they gave their blood so that we might
have Peace and Freedom
and now again people want to take your
freedom away in this new world that I
call craziness disguised as
victimization
check this out
all right everyone
Welcome to our strategy session
with saving the world from the division
and hate that have been plaguing it
but how are we gonna do it well I think
with the problem of racism we can solve
it by teaching people that they're
inherently bad based on the color of
their skin
and also segregating People based on
their skin color ooh I like that like
how now the NFL will be playing a black
national anthem and a white national
anthem before games it's a good first
step in creating more division yes
that's a great idea so good
um I'm not sure that's gonna work what
do you mean well I don't think what
you're proposing is going to help racism
because it is racism you know like what
you're proposing is to judge a person
based on their skin color not the
content of their character yeah well
that's the opposite of what Martin
Luther King preached which was to judge
a person based on the content of their
character not the color of their skin oh
what so you think just because you're a
man you can be educated yeah leave it to
a white guy to bring up Martin Luther
King he's not white I identify him as
Korean and you know Koreans know nothing
about Martin Luther King look what I'm
doing isn't Ray racism I just don't
think you're following me here so let me
explain what I'm saying is that certain
racial groups are superior and other
certain racial groups are inferior yeah
that's racism you just said the
definition of racism look I've got to
print it right here I identify as
illiterate and it is hateful to try to
get our community to read things
literacy is racist quit being so hateful
man I hate you because you're a man see
that's the kind of love we need more of
okay
um moving on
what's your idea for helping the world I
am transgender and non-binary amazing
thank you for your contribution
um so your transgender and non-binary
that's great but did you know those are
two opposite things so you can't be both
at the same time how dare you well no I
mean you're obviously a great person but
what if we could stretch our minds into
objective reality for just a second
transgender means you identify as the
opposite gender you were born as and it
means you're possibly willing to go
through surgeries and hormone treatments
because you identify as that gender so
much yeah and being non-binary means you
don't identify as any gender
and you're saying you're both of these
at the same time yeah well that doesn't
make any sense whoa you're just
attacking her because she's black she's
she's black ask her are you black I do
identify as black you'll never amount to
anything because of your skin color I
don't think you're black look I realize
your cisgender privilege clouds your
reality but if you would just stop
overthinking things you'd realize your
objective reality should be based on my
imagination does that make more sense
now
yeah welcome to the new world of
craziness these people don't want you to
say anything they want you to be afraid
because they are the victims if you say
anything you'll be a sexist racist and
the list just goes on but they are
actually not the victims
you are
they are the one attacking and bullying
people who do not just fall in line with
what they believe their perception of
the truth of themselves in the world
even if you say Hey you can believe what
you want to believe but I want to
believe what I want to believe but then
they are angry no you they want to force
you but I want to tell you today that
doesn't mean that you should stay silent
you should stand up for your own beliefs
as well you have the right to do so
given to you by God you have the right
to make up your own decisions
the freedom to choose
open up your eyes and start to overcome
evil with good Romans 12 21 says do not
be overcome by evil but overcome evil
with good
if good men do not stand up for good
morals and values
in society then we have a big problem
if you don't stand up against strange
men appearing in the locker room or
public toilets where your little girl is
undressing just looking at them
revealing themselves
then we've got a huge problem
it's only going to get worse
and it's been happening because good men
are doing nothing
because you are silent you have fallen
for their trap to think that if you say
anything then you'll be canceled or
labeled as to manly
scared that they will say that your
masculinity is a problem
nonsense the many rational manly men
around the world are being silenced by a
bunch of minority crazies with evil
people behind them
be manly being manly means to protect
yourself and your family
so do it with love
Edmund Burke said all that is required
for evil to Triumph is for good men to
do nothing
being a man is just a matter of birth
but being a great man is a matter of
character so what is it going to take
for you to do anything
maybe you're not doing anything because
it wasn't your wife or your daughter in
the toilet in the bathroom
what is it going to take
are you waiting for that to happen to
you before you do something
Only Fools focus more on treatment than
on prevention when you can see a problem
is coming and you don't do anything
about it when you see a storm is coming
you don't stay on the ocean with a boat
you get a home you lock the doors you
close up you do something about it you
prevent any damage and it's the same way
with your life when you see something is
coming and you don't do anything what do
you think is going to happen
so let me leave you with this
go and overcome all evil forms of just
evil and craziness with good
with love with truth
and always remember that life is short
so don't waste yours
cheers guys